it's a new year that needs new movies
that means new stuff I'm excited about
that's right it's time for my most
anticipated films of 2017 it was going
to be a top ten but then I saw the first
trailer for alien covenant and that one
which had been on the list was yanked
right off and I didn't find a tenth one
so this is going to be the nine movies I
am most looking forward to the reason I
didn't feel the 10th spot is because I
like to do a list of movies I am
genuinely excited for not just hopeful
for there are a number of movies coming
out this year that I hope will be good
but I don't know if i actually have
enough confidence that they will be to
actually be excited about them so here
are the ones i'm actually excited to go
to the theater and see number nine lego
batman how weird is it that to even say
that sentence I can't wait to see the
lego batman but it looks great lego
movie was great Batman was great in that
the trailers have been hilarious is this
wonderful it just sort of capturing this
weird and you know it's a little bit
parody Batman but still feels like a
legit Batman at the same time it's a
great balancing act and I'm really
looking forward to it number eight Logan
this one largely on the strength of the
trailer I'm skeptical about a number of
aspects of it but man that trailer did
sell me I am actually now excited this
is going to be Hugh Jackman's last go
and it really does look like they're
pulling all the stop is gonna be rated R
which I'm not like yeah I guess I mean
I've not been somebody who's really
desperately needed to see Wolverine
viciously tear through people with blood
spurting everywhere but the fact that
they were willing to go there to me says
they want to cap things off the
strongest way they possibly can and I am
I am excited for that and I'm intrigued
by the bits of story we've gotten i'm
probably going to try and avoid any more
trailers between now and when this comes
out because i've gotten enough to know i
want to see it and I don't want to find
out any more about the plot at this
point really number 7 Kong Skull Island
again a good try
killer can maybe excited for a movie
that it was just kind of like oh that's
coming out before the trailer came up
but then I saw it I'm like oh this looks
like so much fun now I actually kind of
like the peter i love the original King
Kong I do actually like peter jackson's
movie a lot of people seem to have
soured on it over time it was one of my
favorite times at the movie the year
that it came out and I do still enjoy it
but it's very dour it has a really
strong sense of fate which is one of the
things that I like about it but I like
that this film is going a different way
with it it looks like it's just being
fun and bonkers and Kong is huge he's
bigger than he's ever been and yeah I am
expecting this to be a good time i'm not
expecting master bi sign just expecting
a good rollicking time because that's
what the trailer sold me on number six
the king's men the Golden Circle this
one we don't have a trailer for as of
when i'm recording this but um so this
is just completely on the strength of
how much I liked the first one first
Kingsman was great and they're bringing
back Colin Firth how are they bringing
back Colin Firth no idea don't care i
love that he's back and i'm intrigued by
the whole idea of like they're going to
the US and the u.s. equivalent agency
and just to see how things very there
and i'm just i'm excited for all the
characters who are coming back i'm
excited to just go and play in this in
this world again and I again much like
Colin I'm just expecting a really good
time number 5 blade runner 2049 now I
have talked about this one already when
the first sort of teaser footage drop so
I won't dwell too much on it now but
yeah it seems like so far from what we
understand it seems like pretty much
every decision being made on this is the
right decision they got a great director
who makes thoughtful beautifully shot
films they are bringing in Harrison Ford
but the director said that they are not
going to do phonetically answer the
question whether or not he's a replicant
there have made their focusing on
practical effects so that this world
will feel real and lived in like it did
in that first film seeing a rival was
what finally got me truly excited to
actually see what this director is
capable
and now yeah I'm pumped number four
guardians of the galaxy two baby Groot
do I even have to say any more than that
baby Groot do I have to say more okay
I'll say a few more I the first one is
so much fun and I there's something
about they love it a little bit more
than me i think the resolution is he
could have used a little work the
villain was a little weak but it's man
it's a good time it is so much fun and
this trailer that we got really evokes
that same sense of fun and i love the
characters being brought back i love the
ones who look like they're being
upgraded from background characters to
be more from center like yondu and
nebula i'm really curious to see how
this whole ego the Living Planet thing
pans out with kurt russell's playing him
but is he living planet is he not what I
how is that working i'm really curious
and that I mean that's the thing this
this world embraces all the insanity of
Marvel cosmic that I just want to see
what they're gonna throw up on the
screen because they got a lot of nutty
stuff to pull from and I know James Gunn
is crazy enough to use it number three
star wars episode 8 whatever it ends up
being called I am fully back on board
with Star Wars I enjoyed the force
awakens i really liked rogue one and i'm
really looking forward to episode 8
because i think ryan Johnson is a
notably better director than JJ Abrams
is so with that kind of talent going on
behind the camera I and I'm sold on
these new characters at this point I'm
really want to see what more we learn
about kylo Ren I Luke's gonna be back
like legitimately will get unfortunately
sadly a swan song for carrie fisher but
we will get to see her be Leia one more
time and you know what in a few years i
may get tired of this we get a new Star
Wars movie every year but we've been
getting more than one Marvel movie every
year I'm not tired of those yet so uh
he'll be okay for a little while
speaking of Marvel movies number two
spider-man homecoming Tom Holland I
think is a great fit for this part he
was great in Civil War he looked great
in the trailer Michael Keaton's the bad
guy I mean how how can you not be
excited for Michael Keaton being the bad
guy to this version of spider-man
is wonderful and I again it's evoking
this wonderful sense of fun and
lightness and they're keeping it
properly scaled it doesn't look like
it's gotta be he must save the city no
he's got to deal with this one crazy guy
with a jetpack and I want to see how
that works and I want to find out more
about how his day-to-day life trying to
be spider-man works and we get bits and
tony stark and i really like Marissa
Tomei in general so I want to see more
of her on May and yeah i'm just-just I
more everything that they're showing me
that is in this film I want it I want it
now I want more so coming in at number
one even more anticipated in spider-man
one of my favorite superheroes ever wore
for the Planet of the Apes now if I'm
being honest the trailer that we got was
good it wasn't great but I love this
series and while the trailer didn't blow
me away there were no red flags in it as
far as I was concerned I loved rise I
thought it was a stupid idea done
wonderfully I adore dawn of the Planet
of the Apes this thing sort of quietly
like at this sort of sleeper motives and
dwelling in my head this has become one
of my favorite franchises of the last
five years this is stuff is so good and
andy serkis is so good to Caesar and
this looks like it could be like a
concluding chapter of this sort of
trilogy of Glee ting us into the planet
of the apes and I'm just pumped for this
I am so excited to see just where it
goes because one of my favorite things
about both films dawn especially I
couldn't pick it down I didn't know what
was gonna happen and it doesn't do when
you see too many movies too many TV
shows it gets harder and harder for
things to surprise you and for things to
go in directions you weren't expecting
you know that aren't like oh it's a
twist like no just narrate just
navigating the story in directions that
you wouldn't have expected and this
series does that and because of that I
am psyched for this movie and it is my
most anticipated movie of 2017 so that's
my list I've got nine on it what whose
are you looking forward to this year
whatever they might be drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to follow me on
Twitter
ad council of geeks please go ahead and
subscribe hit that Bell down there so
that you get notifications when I put up
new stuff you can check out the council
of geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned